today House Democrats embarrass
themselves by passing a resolution to
approve an impeachment inquiry that they
had already been conducting for weeks
behind closed doors now from the
beginning their pattern of leaking and
lying to damage Trump in an election
year of course was so obvious it was so
it was so cheesy it reminds me of one of
those old movies that kind of scared you
as a kid but then made you laugh as an
adult
these creatures are very haunting
[Music]
our house that's what Nancy thinks well
Pelosi and shifts act it's just as kind
of goofy as that it's not believable at
all
suddenly they care about honoring the
intent of the framers the founders
provided the remedy the framers gave
only this Congress the power if need be
to impeach the founders didn't want a
king they didn't want a dictator they
didn't want a monarch they said Mr
Francis Penn what did we have a monarchy
or republican they said about the
Constitution I half-expected Nancy to
show up in a revolutionary waistcoat
okay thankfully though Republicans are
calling this out for the horror show
that it is this impeachment is not only
an attempt to undo the last election is
it an attempt to influence the next one
as well this is not what Democrats
promised when they entered the majority
11 months ago I guess it's only fitting
you take this vote on Halloween and on
Halloween people are looking for treats
and Democrats only offered lame tricks
like the absurd notion that they're
approaching this solemn moment with open
minds only the facts and how we respond
to them will dictate the outcome I make
no prejudgment as to whether that remedy
will be warranted then they tried to
disguise their venal motives by wrapping
themselves like mummifying themselves in
the Constitution that is the duty of
this house to vindicate the Constitution
to honor the oath to defend the
Constitution that each of us took we
must move forward with this impeachment
inquiry for his top well we see right
through all of this boys and the
dressing it all up as Uncle Sam didn't
make them any more credible it isn't
about partisanship
it's about patriotism we're here too
because brave dedicated public servants
and patrons are standing up for their
country well dedicated public servants
would be doing the people's work of
passing an infrastructure bill the u.s.
MCA and lowering the cost of
prescription drugs but none of that's
happening they're dedicated all right
they're dedicated to the art of really
bad acting I take no joy in
contemplating the impeachment of a
president is not a decision that any of
us makes lightly you know today was a
solemn day it's one that none of us you
know really look forward to this entire
thing is a Saturday Night Live skit okay
they've been dying to have this day
happen okay they've been looking forward
to this since the moment Trump put his
hand on the Bible you had a Democrat
dirty trick that started this whole
thing the so-called whistle blower the
guy who took his case to shift staff
first is what really blows the lid off
this entire saga according to real clear
investigations he worked for Biden yes
he worked for Biden on Ukraine policy
when Biden was VP he worked for deep
state henchmen Brennan too and the
whistleblower also reportedly worked for
Susan Rice no conflicts of interest here
at all more on this later on in the show
none of these Democrats though in the
end as that first movie clip made clear
should be taken seriously their
partisans they have no philosophy or
agenda that will actually end up making
your lives better their policies to the
extent that there are any spawn only
economic misery and less freedom for you
and for me it's an understatement to say
that this is a witch hunt
but remember witches have their day but
we all know what happens to them in the
last real
[Music]
[Music]
ouch and that's the angle